all right i'm going to get started
welcome to lecture
16 of 14 13. we talked a lot about
utility from beliefs and how in
particular anticipatory utility
utility about thinking about the future
and what might happen in the future
may affect people's utility and then you
know how that in turn might affect how
people
a choose when to consume or when to
engage in certain activities because you
know anticipatory utility
provides some motivation to push things
forward at least a little bit
so people can look forward to positive
events
second we talked about information
acquisition about
the idea that people if they derive
utility from beliefs
that might affect how much information
they might
want to acquire in particular we talked
about the idea that
when you think about like potentially
negative information
that you might receive in particular we
talked about huntington's disease when
people had like
negative health information um that they
might not want that information
um with the motivation that they would
like to make themselves
um feel better about themselves they
might sort of think that
they're healthier than they actually are
they might look forward to like a
healthy life at least 14 more years
and that might depress their um
willingness to gather or receive
information
now we talked a little bit about then
a model and how to think about this
uh first we talked about a model um
where people did not have the choice
whether they could um manipulate
the information themselves so we just
talked about like
when somebody wants to seek or reject
information but we had the uh constraint
we had opposed to constraint and we go
back for a second
we had a constraint imposed but we said
well the person needs to be
um hold correct beliefs conditional on
the information that they have been
exposed to so far
so essentially that was just an idea of
like okay here's some information that
the person could
um gather and but the constraint was
this number one that i'm showing you
here is that beliefs need to be
correct as in like the person is a
bayesian
conditional on the information that they
have received so far
um and then we sort of said well if you
think about this if this is just about
like
when to gather information um and we
are considered so far the case where the
person could not actually affect
future outcomes so that's the case of
like say huntington's disease where
there's no cure there's nothing you can
do about it
the question was just like would you
like to receive some information that's
going to happen in the future
or not let me um and i'm not going to go
to this
in detail very much we then looked at
the conditions
um that involved for when does the
person want to know about this
and the condition was essentially about
this function of f of p
where f of p was essentially the utility
uh derived from
um beliefs and the condition was either
if f is concave where f is convex if f
is concave the person is information
averse if after is convex the person is
information loving and would like to
find out about those things now that
means that well consider now also the
possibility that people might
be able to manipulate their beliefs
right so you might sort of say
um what are the reasons why might you
ever want to hold correct beliefs
and then the above framework if you
could choose work your peers there's
really no reason whatsoever to not
choose p
equals one remind remember uh p here was
the probability of your health being
good of being hd hunting disease
negative of
not having disease so if there's no
negative consequences of what's going to
happen in the future
surely you'll have all the incentives in
the world to deceive yourself and make
yourself think that you are
healthy right and so now then the
question was like well
um and this is what i was showing you
here this is the expression that's here
there's essentially f of one and that's
uh larger than f of p for any p that are
there
and then if the future this is the term
here what is actually going to happen in
the future
if that's independent of your um
of your um beliefs in the sense of like
that's going to happen anyway
you might as well um make yourself
believe that
uh uh p is as large p is one you're
healthy
now then what we left things on was the
question of
like well my why might you not want to
choose f of one anyway
why not do not wanna say uh p equals one
and that's a question to you
if your belief of what's going to happen
might affect the future outcome
in a negative way
um like i guess if there were treatment
available for hunting with
huntington's disease you would rather
know whether you have it
right so um huntington's is not the
greatest of all examples that i chose to
start with because you know uh
there's no cure um but you're right like
for example in particular
for diseases such as hiv or the like
surely it would be very helpful to know
because then you can sort of
engage in appropriate treatment that
might actually help you get better
presumably you only get the treatment if
you actually know what the disease is
like
in the specific huntington's disease we
also talked about a few things we talked
about sort of other actions that you
might be able to take
for example um if you are able to
um uh you know save for retirement
if you're able to go to travels before
you get sick or like
there was questions about whether people
want to have children questions about
like uh what partners they want to be
with and so on and so forth
so if there's a bunch of sort of other
economic choices or other choices in
life
that depend on whether the person is
positive or negative
it seems like that person should want to
know and then sort of deluding yourself
might get in the way of making
optimal decisions but broadly speaking
uh
just to summarize if there is no action
item as in like if there's some
information about the future that where
really
even if you knew the information um
uh there's nothing you could do about
what's going to happen in the future
um it's not obvious why do not want to
just loot yourself
and think like things are rosie or the
world is looking better
um than it actually is because it might
just make you um happier at least in the
moment
even if things in the future might turn
out to be
bad and so uh this is what we already
just discussed so
incorrect beliefs can lead to mistaken
decisions well um
that's correct but sort of overly
positive beliefs are an economically
important implication of utility from
beliefs
that is to say on the one hand and
you might this is what we just discussed
you want to believe that you're healthy
if it makes you feel
uh better about yourself or currently of
the future so you might want to convince
yourself
that uh that's the case but uh this is
what we just said over optimism
of the sorts decision making in some
ways for example health behavior whether
you want to seek treatment
but also whether you want to sort of
adjust to potentially bad events and
some other ways
and economic choices um uh
uh so you might not want to so you might
not want to be
like over optimistic um um because
uh uh because uh of those distortions
and then sort of the optimal
expectations will then trade off these
two things
on the one hand you're healthier maybe
happier right now thinking
you're healthy on the other hand or
thinking that the future will be bright
anyway
on the other hand it might make uh
change your choices
right in some bad way now there was
another reason that people mentioned
which was
um potential for disappointment right if
you think you know
the future is always going to be great
even if you can't
affect it in any way well at some point
reality is gonna set in and then you
might get really um
disappointed we haven't really talked
about this very much that's a way in
which you can think about perhaps
people potentially choosing their
reference point so if you think people
have like reference dependent utility
and if you really were optimistic um
very much
in a way that allows you to potentially
choose your expectations and your
um your reference point and then you
know you might not want to be
overly optimistic because your reference
point might
be then too high and any uh outcomes
that you then eventually
receive uh you might sort of view uh
worse because you expect the league of
things to happen so to the extent that
like um
being too or being overly optimistic
leads to disappointment
you might not want to engage in
over-optimism even if there's
nothing you can do about the outcomes
because of that potential disappointment
but sort of in general um for decision
making with a disciplinary utility at
least some of the optimism leads to
higher utility than realism
uh because essentially um it makes you
feel better
uh in the moment but there's sort of
this trade-off potentially with
how good you feel at the moment versus
how disappointed you might be in the
future
in case you're too over optimistic
any questions about this
sorry
okay so then um let me show you some
other
optimistic um uh beliefs in addition to
the uh
evidence by emily hospital i already
showed you
so there's a classic sort of study by
1980 that asks students to make
judgments off their
students chances for now outcomes it's
kind of similar to the question that i'd
ask you
at the beginning of class there are two
measures that weinstein uses one is
what's called
judgment this is um
excuse me
this is how much more or less likely the
average student thinks
um the event will happen to them
relative to the average student
and the second one is what's called the
optimistic pessimistic ratio
the number of students who think their
chances are better than the average
classmates divided by the number who
think their chances are
worse so these are both sort of measures
of over-optimism they measure slightly
different things but they're broadly
fairly highly correlated so what does
weinstein find
clear sort of evidence of over-optimism
when you look at different things about
like stuff that's going to happen in
your life
owning a house a salary of larger than
ten thousand dollars a year i think this
is you know 1980 that's been a while ago
uh traveling to europe living past age
80 and so on
the comparative judgment is always
fairly high so that number would be zero
uh if people were
on average realistic remember
comparative judgment is how much more or
less likely the average student thinks
yeah it will happen to them relative to
the average actual average student
and um uh the optimistic pessimistic
ratio that should be like um
um a one if people were sort of like um
not over optimistic it's also clearly
a large n1 remember that's the number of
students who think their chances are
better than the average classmates
divided by the number who think their
chances are worse
but works for positive events but also
works for negative events
so when you ask people about like
drinking problems um suicide divorce
heart attacks all sorts of bad things
people think they're now of course less
likely to
to um happen to them these kinds of
events
um and then again the optimistic
pessimistic ratio that's positive that's
just because it's like um
the outcome is flipped so people are way
more optimistic or
about they think they're not going to
have drinking problems
get divorced get heart attacks and so on
so people tend to be very optimistic
about their
future lives
now there's other um examples of that
couples believe there's a small chance
that their marriage will end
uh small scale business small business
owners think their business is far more
likely to succeed
than their uh typical similar business
smokers understand the health risks go
smoking but don't believe these risks
apply specifically to them but the long
list of kind of these kinds of behaviors
people tend to um have very hold rosy
beliefs about
their future even in the presence of
like sort of objective information so
even if you give people information
about the health risk of smoking
they understand the health risk but then
they're like well that's not going to
apply to me
of course there's no good reason to
actually smoke this should apply to
anybody
so people just want some things to be
true
presumably because it makes them happier
in some ways
so then uh beyond future prospects
people also tend to have overly positive
positive views about their abilities and
traits so for example 99 of drivers
uh think they're better than the average
driver 94 percent of
professors at the university of nebraska
i think they're better teachers than the
avid professor at the university
i don't know what this number looks at
like at mit but probably it's larger
than
um uh 50 as well so this
you can find this kind of evidence from
range of domains
in some cases there's some other
potential explanation for this
but broadly speaking there's pretty
robust evidence that people are
um overconfident and overly positive
about hey what's going to happen to them
in the future and be about
thinking about their own skills and
abilities
now um if you look at mit students
however in in contrast
when you ask mit students different
questions and this is from a recent
survey from a few years ago that mit
sort of asked
students uh one question here is
academically i would consider myself
above average
at mit um uh you know people say about
31
of students say they're above average in
particular um
female students tend to think they're
below
average people might have biased beliefs
about the average so what you think is
an average mit student might actually be
like the fifth or whatever like the some
of the highest percentile because
essentially you're exposed to all the
success and
uh math olympics and whatever like uh
wins that people uh receive which is
just not what the the average student is
like
there's of course also like very severe
selection in terms of like there's so
many smart
and brilliant people um at mit that in a
way sort of people's perception is quite
biased
the questions here were asked about the
average at mit
but even there i think people might sort
of
um adjust the bias in terms of thinking
what's the average
there might also be some worries about
disappointment and a sense of this is
what i was saying before when you think
about like being overconfident
um maybe in some ways so one
issue with or one reason why you might
not end up
being overconfident for a long time is
if you receive feedback
and at mit you know people receive lots
of exams and so on
um where you can sort of learn or
interact with others where you can sort
of notice
um how people are doing a role and sort
of if you're worried about being
disappointed or you have been
disappointed several times already
then sort of thinking like you're the
smartest person in class
um uh it might not be a good idea
because you might get
disappointed again and then um
we'll talk a little bit more about
gender in a different lecture later
that's a very common uh theme one second
um
is that female mit students or
in general women but in particular also
female mit students are particularly
overcome underconfident
we don't exactly know why that is but
it's a very
robust finding not just at mit in some
ways then
um there's still a question so it's a
very nice observation that
in a way beliefs can also be a form of
self
motivation so if you sort of are really
interested in
academic success and being really
good at exams and so on and so forth if
you
are under confident that can be a
motivator and saying like you're really
worried about failing you're
worried about doing badly and so on then
you work extremely hard
and then you do better in exams you
surprise yourself positively
that can be sort of an important um
motivator of course that could also go
the other way it could be really
discouraging if you think you're really
terrible on everything
then you might sort of at the end of the
day um you might not study at all
anymore because like what's the point so
there's a bit of a
a trade-off here as well and it could be
that
um uh if you sort of think that
people are when they're under confident
that leads to motivation and it makes
them better
um uh um at school plus they're gonna be
less disappointed
uh and get like positive surprises that
could be an explanation
i think there's a bit of a question
again why is that the case at mit and
not sort of in the overall population
but it might have to do with like the
frequency of feedback and like school
and and so on and so forth and maybe
also just with social norms or other
things that maybe are
uh somewhat trickier to explain i was
teaching harvard undergrads as a grad
student
i'm not so sure that harvard students
are under under confidence to be honest
uh uh i haven't seen the survey evidence
on that but um
my my my senses that mit students are
more underconfident
compared to harvard students let's let's
leave it at that
but i think it's true like if you look
at caltech and other uh
type of schools that are very similar to
mit i think my guess is
you'll find similar results in those
kinds of
surveys
okay so um the next thing we talked
about
is very quickly is what's called ego
utility so far they only talked about
anticipatory utility which was the idea
that people want to look forward to
uh good things in life um and therefore
um
um they're um uh sort of have inflated
beliefs about what's going to happen in
the future
a very um related um aspect is what's
called um ego utility
which is um so so just to recap inflated
beliefs might be explained by
anticipatory utility essentially to say
um
higher ability means better future
prospects and people want to convince
themselves that they have high ability
and therefore um if you think you're
very smart that means like good things
going to happen in the future
but um it might also just be like right
now
um you're just feeling better about
yourself and therefore
um um uh you have like inflated beliefs
about yourself
so that's often like tricky to
distinguish empirically in a sense of
like i might just feel like
i'm good looking uh smart and so on and
so forth because it makes me feel
good right now or i might want to hold
those beliefs because
um uh that means like good thing is good
things is gonna happen in the future and
i
will have a bright future um going
forward
so these things are slightly tricky to
to disentangle
and both of them probably play an
important role
at the end of the day so um
yeah now um one thing i'm going to talk
about a little bit more
also later in the semester is about
mental health and so there is this
literature
that sort of argues that positive
illusions are
promote in fact psychological well-being
so that's sort of the argument that is
here that um uh over-confident
is in fact vital or important for
maintaining mental health
so you know over-confident and that
makes people like i'm
happier it's um people are better able
to care for others if they think they
themselves are doing better
uh they're better at doing uh creative
and productive work
that's also better overconfident helps
people manage
negative feedback so overall all of
those things are like um
are or so this literature argues that
overconfidence actually helps people
with their everyday lives in particular
helps people maintain a positive
a good mental uh health and there's sort
of this um
um a term called depressive realism
which is uh to say that
realistic expectation might actually be
detrimental to mental health so that the
world is just difficult and various ways
bad things gonna happen uh are happening
um in many
alliance and if people are not overly
optimistic about
um what's going to happen in the future
and so on they might be happy and bad
for their um
mental health we'll return to this issue
on um
on happiness and mental health in a
later lecture but i wanted to
flag this these things are very much
like linked to each other
um and another sort of reason perhaps
why um
over-optimism might be in fact um um
good or like not detrimental is because
not only makes makes people happier but
it might also help people
protect their mental health
okay so then um just very briefly and
this is sort of more like uh there's
some research and some of those things
some this is more
anecdotal what are some factors that
affects the extent of positive biases
so people tend to have greater biases in
fact with respect to prospects and
traits that are personally important to
them
on the one hand you might say well
people should also be better informed
about those things
but to the extent that it affects a
utility um they might be more biased
right from stuff that's really important
to you
you might be more biased because that's
precisely what's going to make you
happier
available or imminent objective
information tends to decrease
biases as i'm like and this is kind of
what i was talking about
with mit students when you think about
sort of academic performance
you get lots and lots of feedback every
single semester so in a way it's it's
more difficult to be
overly optimistic or to to maintain an
overly optimistic
picture of your your academic self if
you get all these
um objective signals over and over again
so one prediction here would be that for
example if you looked at first second
and third and fourth year
students that perhaps some of the
uh underconfidence only um comes later
in the semester
of course uh um there's other reasons
why that might not be the case
then the feedback about the prospect or
any prospect is more ambiguous and
similar to interpretation biases tend to
be greater
so particularly people are particularly
biased in situations where people get
ambiguous feedback where
like you can interpret things either way
so you know um
either you were like really smart and
did something really great or you're
just lucky
and people tend to and many things in
life people
tend to interpret sort of lucky things
that happened um
in their lives tend to think that um
those are due to skills
and there's a very nice work and book by
robert frank he's at cornell a
university who sort of argues that
people
tend to interpret a lot of things that
happen in their lives
uh that really are just mostly luck they
tend to think that
um it's due to their amazing abilities
and so on and sort of
uh and that's the reason for that often
is that a lot of this feedback or like a
lot of this information is ambiguous you
can interpret it either way
and people like to think that good
things are because they did really great
and bad things are because they just
happen to be unlucky
um if people and that's quite
interesting if people feel like they
have control over the outcomes biases um
um tend to be greater uh expertise
sometimes
increases biases um but not for experts
who get very good feedback so
meteorologists or the like who get like
lots of feedback all the time
they actually tend to not be
overconfident because again like if you
get so much feedback all the time it's
hard to sort of maintain your over
optimism
okay so now one question you might sort
of have as well i showed you a bunch of
data information on bias beliefs but not
a lot in actual action of course the
testing behavior
and the hunting season so now some
actions
but a lot of the stuff on the weinstein
and other studies were just about
self-reported beliefs and one question
you might have is well this is about
self-reports what about like real
preference on choices that people make
so there's some evidence um that's from
lab experiments and there's some other
evidence that i'll show you
um that are sort of about actual choices
so one very nice experiment is the
paper by ellen rao from 2010. the way
this works is people are
given feedback about some people doing
iq tests and they're rated according to
their physical attractiveness
by others and uh in this study
and they get feedback about sort of this
iq test score and their physical
attractiveness
these two things are chosen presumably
because people care a lot about them
people care about how smart they are
people also care about how
good looking they are and then so in the
study the authors elicit
people's prior beliefs the beliefs at
the beginning before they receive
information
about a rank between one and ten so
people are put in groups of ten and then
sort of ask about
like in a group of 10 people how do you
think you rank um
compared to others and then um
people get um some information and they
get in particular
bilateral comparisons with another
participant in the group
and then the author solicited their
serious
beliefs after receiving this information
and also the willingness to pay for
true ranks and broadly speaking what the
authors find
is there's asymmetric processing of
objective information about the
in particular when people receive
positive news so when somebody says
you've been compared to another person
in the in the study
and you're like better looking or like
you have a better iq score
um than this other person people tend to
be roughly beijing as in like they tend
to be like pretty good at actually sort
of updating based on that information
in contrast when people receive
unfavorable use uh
news they tend to essentially discount
the signals um
and they they tend to essentially not
really react to that information
so that's very much consistent with
people are very happy to receive
positive feedback and they're actually
good at sort of integrating it as in
like they're
they're good at sort of doing the the
the math as albasian
would want them to but once they get
negative feedback to essentially mostly
just
scout that information presumably and
very much consistently with
motivated beliefs people tend to want to
have
positive images of themselves there's
also some evidence of people a
willingness to pay for information if
they think their information will be
good
and not going to pay for information if
they think the information will be
balanced if they're low in
in their ranks again people want to hear
good things about themselves
and they learn more or they're willing
to learn more when they receive positive
news
they're also willingness uh willing to
pay more for information that they think
will be positive there's some other
evidence that's
similar to that there's a very nice
similar paper by mobius
that's very similar to elon rao there's
some very nice work by
tom by um florian zimmerman
unmotivated memory so that people argue
that
it's not just about when people update
immediately some people are given
positive or negative information
they update differently but what um
foreign shows is that
in his work that once people are given
this information in fact in his
experiment
there is no asymmetric updating in the
short run so when people are given this
information about this is about like how
they did in the test
uh in germany in the short run people
seem to actually
be um not overly optimistic in the
updating
but then a month later when the author
goes back to people and asks them about
uh the information that they have
received and their beliefs
people tend to remember positive signals
more than negative signals
and that sort of suggests that memory
can play an important role in the
formation of motivated beliefs
when stuff happens good stuff people
remember more and bad
things um not so much now those are all
kind of like lab types experiments where
people are incentivized to give correct
answers but in a way it's sort of um
somewhat contrived there's also quite a
bit of evidence in
a real world setting in particular when
it comes to like
finance or trading behavior for example
there's barber or nordian that shows
that
looks at overconfident small small-scale
investors men for example tend to trade
a lot more than
uh women we also know from other
settings that men tend to be more
overconfident
than women those men then also lose more
money or make
less money plausibly uh due to
overconfidence
with this type of evidence it's often a
little tricky because um it's hard to
say
is it to do to gender is it due to
overconfidence or maybe other things
that are correlated with this
um but there's quite a bit of evidence
on on that kind of behavior that
essentially um overconfidence leads to
worse decision
here in this case um uh trading
decisions
there's also a very nice paper by uh
uruguay monica
and tate on managerial hubris they have
a clever way of identifying
overconfident managers
which essentially is managers that are
overconfident there are holding stock
options of their own stocks
so you're not supposed to do that um
and you will most likely do that only if
you think you know your company is going
to do really great
compared to other companies instead you
sort of exercise you should exercise
your stock options and sort of diversify
um and not sort of be overly invested in
your own firm but if you sort of think
that
um are you really great um or your firm
is really great
um uh uh you might not want to do that
and precisely those
over confident managers engage their
businesses and more main mergers and
those mergers um i mean
sort of a show where in fact are not um
not good people tend to do
too many mergers um that would
essentially destroy value
presumably due to overconfidence so
there that there's that kind of
um evidence as well so overall we sort
of think there's quite a bit of evidence
of people systematically holding over
optimistic beliefs
and those overly optimistic beliefs are
affecting people's
choices in a way that makes them worse
off in some ways
in particular sort of finance choices
where people tend to lose or destroy
value okay
any questions on this before i move on
to
heuristics and biases
okay so then um uh you know we talked
about
um uh three of our four um uh issues
here already
um the last thing that we haven't talked
about very much is to say bayesian
learning is just really hard and
people might just not be good at it not
for any
motivated reasons or because you know of
any utility reasons for the like
anticipatory or eu
utility but it just might be really hard
to do when people essentially use like
heuristics because it's too hard to
compute these things
on their own now um
we talked about this already quite a bit
sort of lots of economic choices are
made under uncertainty
almost anything in life involves some
uncertainty
so we need to kind of know something
about the likelihood of relevant events
and sort of you know you
you if you if you decide which topic in
the course to focus on when you study
for an exam and you only have like one
night to do so
if a basketball coach decides whether to
to leave tired players on the game
you kind of make some probabilistic
judgment about like which player is
going to be best
many medical managerial and educational
career decisions essentially all those
kinds of decisions
are involving probabilities of there's
some probability of good things
happening some probabilities of bad
things happen
and you need to make some estimates
about those probabilities
now how to make individuals
probability probabilistic uh uh judge
instrument of this kind
so far when we talked about risk
preferences earlier in the semester
we essentially looked at like how do
people make these choices for given
probabilities right that was essentially
prospect theory that was about kahneman
and tursky 1979
which was you know how do people think
about risk and what we always assumed
was that the probability
distribution was like given there's a 50
chance of something good happenings 50
chance of something bad happening and
now how do people uh uh
make those kinds of choices what does
their utility function look like
now we're going to talk about like how
do people learn about such probabilities
how
in the first place do they update uh
what probabilities are
like which is of course a very important
um
uh input in their decision making now
then and then this is sort of based on
pioneering work by
uh conor manatee even earlier than the
79 paper this is a particular
paper on 1974 which is um uh
in the reading list and on the course um
website
now first i want to start with an
instance i think important in behavioral
economics to sort of acknowledge and try
to sort of
emphasize you know people are pretty
rational and pretty good in in
various ways in the sense of people get
lots of things right
in particular people are pretty good in
terms of like broad directions
um of people's probability judgments
uh here's some very simple example um
imagine you're deciding whether to see
the new
um james cameron movie this could be a
jim's camera movie it could be a korean
drama or anything else
i think people think about like they
want to watch something new
well how are you going to do that well
you can read some online reviews you
heard hear some
opinions from your friends you look up
some rotten tomato or other ratings and
then you sort of try to make those kinds
of
um choices and so you start maybe
probably with like okay have i seen
like a james cameron movie before or is
that green drama or whatever you're
interested in
um have i seen something like this
before uh how much did i like the
previous one
that could be like your prior that you
start with and then you get these other
pieces of information of online reviews
um various opinions from friends or a
rotten tomato ratings and how do you use
those then what do you do with those
so essentially what you're going to do
is um you take some you have some prior
which is about kind of like about
james cameron movies or whatever to
start with and that's kind of like
that that that's what you used to start
with in the first place
and then you get essentially these
pieces of information and if there's
sort of positive
um pieces of information about those
specific movies then you're going to
update
up and if they're bad if they sort of if
your friends don't like it as you said
um they update down notice that it could
also be that you have a friend who is
like terrible taste in movies
and if that friend does not like a movie
that you sort of update the other the
other way and so on so it doesn't need
to be that like your friends
um movie ratings are positively
correlated with yours
um that could still be informative if
somebody has terrible movie taste and
like something that could be actually
a good news for the particular movie but
exactly um this is some what i have here
essentially what you're going to do is
the version of this will be
you start with like your your your base
rate or your prior
um and then essentially you use um uh
the various pieces of information and
then sort of adjust your probability up
or down
suppose you have to sort of your
willingness to pay or your probability
of seeing the movie or doing other
things
uh your probability of liking the movie
um you adjust it up or down
based on the different pieces of
information that we get and so
generally people are pretty and this is
a pretty reasonable and sort of
mathematical
mathematically well-founded procedure
this is actually pretty close to what a
bayesian would
would do so people actually pretty good
at this you know
they're pretty they understand so that
the basics of forming likelihood
estimates
they know the direction in which um
features of baseline likelihood and
available information should affect
estimates
so overall people are um pretty good
now what's much harder to do is not just
the direction but also the extent to
which you should update
that is to say people know kind of which
direction to to
um to move as in like if if you and i
like the similar movies and i tell you
this movie was great it's pretty clear
that he should move upwards but it's
much
harder to understand is like by how much
should you move upwards in your estimate
of how good the movie or the probability
that you like the movie um
is and so um and that's true for many
things in life people are pretty good at
the direction in terms of like where to
move up or down
what they're much worse at is you know
how far to adjust their estimates
um and that's uh you know where they
should be using bayes rule but that's
extremely cognitively demanding and so
in many situations people tend to not
get that
right now um
just to sort of remind you when i think
in recitation you discuss this as well
what is bayes rule or how does space
will
work let me just go very quickly through
that and then focus on the
next evidence uh here's one example
suppose you have a coin
um that you start up thinking as a is
fair with probability two thirds
that means like the coin is biased
towards head so the coin is like heads
and tails
uh it's biased towards heads with uh
probability one-third in which case
heads comes up um
75 of the time now if you flip the coin
and it comes up uh uh h heads uh what's
the probability of that
uh uh that it's fair um clearly it
should be like sort of um
um two thirds because you know um you
got like some signal
but by how much should you adjust is
actually very hard to do so you can
think about this in your head and you'll
you realize it's actually kind of hard
to do
unless you can actually write it down so
suppose you had to make a very quick
decision in particular
it's actually very hard to do this uh
quickly on your own you can do this
particularly with one signal but suppose
you get like several signals it gets
much harder and harder over time
now how would you do this you can sort
of in this particular case you can just
do a graphical illustration again i'll
do this very quickly but you can read
about it
um overall you can think about this sort
of two types of um
um uh coins or like earns there's a fair
coin uh that's like
uh represented by an urn with equal
number of heads and uh
tail balls and there's an unfair coin
which is represented by an urn
in which 75 of the balls are each so
you don't know whether the coin is fair
so you don't know which earn you're
drawing from
and one way to think about this is
imagine you're drawing from an urn that
contains both of those urns of course
you need to sort of then also take into
account the probability of the
fair ball being two thirds so the fair
earn has like twice as many balls as
the um unfair one so you can sort of
represent it
in that way and then suppose you you
know you draw a ball randomly and it's h
what's the probability that
it came from the fairer and again if
you're taking sort of probability
um classes and so on um that should be
um
relatively simple for you to calculate
but here in the graphical way you can
make this very simple there's
essentially
seven red balls there's four and a four
and the fair coin and three in the
unfair coin
so probability that came from the fair
coin uh uh is
uh uh four seven similarly if you draw
like
uh a t then the probability came from
the fair iron is uh
uh four fifth right and and that's in
some sense
you know you can write down the math and
it's pretty clear and so on but in a way
that you it's hard to do this in your
head in a sense that you know that
should be a lot lower than two-thirds
but like how much lower and how much
should you adjust is actually kind of
hard
and here the answer happens to be um 4
7.
and so here's the sort of the the
the formal way of doing this i'm not
going to go to this but trust me the
answer is
um 4 7. now
even this simple example of bayes rule
maybe it was very simple for you but
um it's it's somewhat difficult to
follow in the sense of like
would you have gotten the four sevens
right immediately if i gave you 10
seconds
maybe maybe not but probably um quite a
few of you would have gotten it
um wrong now in addition then if you
um try to apply these kinds of rules of
the bayes rule in new situations with
multiple pieces of different information
is far more difficult
suppose i told you you draw like 17
times and get those signals and without
replacement or with replacement and so
on
um things would get way way more
difficult
and the earned example is in fact a much
easier one because there
um i come at least at least i'm telling
you exactly what the probabilities are
but in many real world situations you
don't even know that the friend telling
you the movie is good or bad
it's not clear how to read that signal
how do you think about that signal
um so but most people don't know the
precise
rule of bayes rule i guess at mit most
students do but
in the general population people don't
and even if they do they can't or don't
want to think uh
uh think so hard in many cases so what
people do instead they use intuitive
shortcuts
to make judgments of um of likelihoods
now that's a good thing so like we want
people to use these shortcuts because
otherwise they will just freeze and not
be able to make any choices so in some
sense it's good that people are sort of
simplifying problems and they make some
choices
quickly so that's in some sense it's
good
but it also leads to systematic mistakes
right because in some sense
you can do shortcuts and they help you
to get things like approximately
right but now if we can sort of
understand their
shortcuts then we can also understand
their potentially their systematic
mistakes so
so what people tend to do is they focus
on
wanders or like a small set of the
situation at hand that seems most
relevant they focus on that to make
their decision
and often then they sort of they
systematically neglect
other more complicated or other issues
of the situation which makes their um
the likelihood of their
their estimates typically incorrect and
now the question is can we sort of
understand what people focus on
and can we understand what causes these
systematic biases
uh to sort of make clear predictions on
how people
do things wrongly and then perhaps if
you want to help people make better
choices
you can provide them with development
information as well
now um one
particular interesting issue is uh
sequences of random outcomes
so as i just showed you if you sort of
draw balls from an urn that's a very
relevant
um situation not because people in the
real world in robot situations draw
balls from earns
but rather because in many situations
you do actually get repeated signals
over time
that you should use to update so an
investor might observe past performance
mutual funds but prefer deciding which
one to invest in a patient or doctor
might observe the outcome of prior
surgeries before deciding whether
to undertake the surgery or which doctor
to choose
a coach can observe the recent
performance of a basketball player
before deciding whether to put the
player
in the game there's lots of kinds of
situations where people get repeated
signals over time
and then have to sort of try to infer
likelihoods or probabilities
of certain events um to happen so that's
a very common thing in the world that
we should try and understand now one
systematic pattern that we see in the
world is is what's called the gambler's
fallacy that's the false belief that in
a sequence of independent draws
from a distribution an outcome that
hasn't occurred for a while
is more likely to come up on the next
draw
so the important part he was doing a lot
of work here is independent
draws suppose there's a distribution of
outcomes and there's
independent draws which means that
essentially
what matters and what happened in the
last two three or four draws
should not have any effect of what's
going to happen in the next one
right so if you play roulette or any
sort of like poker or the leg
if you get like red several times in a
row
um that has exactly no uh impact on like
how likely it is that red or
black is is is coming up in the next
straw
but people tend to have to this almost
like folk knowledge of um
well if red came up a few times now
black is due
the other way around um
and that's true in many different
situations where but the important part
here is that
there's a sequence of independent draws
so as in to say
um uh uh you know
these are situations where the
probability distribution is actually
known
that is to say when you play roulette or
like you go to casino
it's not like you need to like learn
about what's the probability that the
roulette is like
fair or not you know that like there's
some monitoring and so on in those
situations
um you know essentially that the chance
of getting red or black is like the same
um and yet people tend to make these uh
kinds of updates
there's a nice paper by golden hester an
old paper uh uh that sort of
shows this quite nicely in which
subjects are told the coin uh
with the black and the red side would be
flipped 25 times
and the experiments are slightly sneaky
here because essentially they actually
um they reported people a predetermined
sequence of events so there's some
deception involved here which is
a little bit trickier but it's mostly
fine so what they see is essentially uh
the subject seems 17 mixed
um coin flips so you see a sequence of
coin flips uh
it's red and black and so on and then at
the end of it you see
essentially um one black and four
um reds and so again this is supposed to
be like independent draws which
would just to make this case in this
experiment they sort of rigged um
uh the last five um uh draws which is
not quite
ideal but let's just go with this for um
for a bit
and so what essentially people see in
this experiment is mostly
mostly
evidence of red and black where roughly
red and black is even
if anything so the 17 are mixed these
are actual draws
if anything people saw more red than
they saw on black
then on the 23rd flip after seeing these
22 flips to start with the partisan
where participants were given a choice
between
um 70 points for sure or 100 points
if the next flip was their color and
points are essentially the stuff they
get
can get money for eventually and so now
it's randomly chosen whether half of the
subject's color was red and half of them
um was black and so now the propensity
to take the 70 points reveals
uh the beliefs about the odds that the
next flip um
uh would be their color so if you
if you think the probability is fifty
percent
uh which is kind of like giving the
information that you got you should
probably roughly think it's it's fifty
percent
then um and if you risk a verse in
particular you should surely choose the
70 points for sure
um because you know an expectation if
it's you get p times 100 if it's 50
you get like essentially 50. right so
you're only going to choose the 100
points if the next flip is your color
well if you really think you know
um uh your color is likely to occur
in particular if your probability of
that occurring is like 70
or higher notice that that even assumes
like risk neutrality
right so if people are risk neutral if
they think the probability is uh 70
they should be indifferent and again if
they're just neutral if they choose
um number two here their color well
that's only the case if they think the
probability
of the color occurring is higher than 70
okay and sort of given that the evidence
that they saw
it's going to be rarely the case that or
people shouldn't really
given the evidence that's there the best
thing they can do is essentially
or the thing is set up such that they
usually should choose number one
um but of course if people think that
the idea is here if people think that
there was four times red so now black is
due
the prediction would be that people um
will be more likely or
will choose um item number two if their
color is
black okay and so um
24 um of 29 red subjects
uh chose to take the short thing which
essentially is option one here that i
showed you
and eight of these of the the black
subjects did so these are essentially
the people who choose
um uh their color so if people have
black as their color
they essentially choose um this option
because they really think like now
um black is due because you know there's
been like essentially
um uh four reds in a row now again
if you're uh told and that's a little
bit unclear this experiment
about like these being independent
independent events which for coin flips
really they should be independent events
that doesn't make any sense you should
if anything um
uh i think red is more likely because
the coin might be sort of more likely to
be read
um but sort of thinking that red black
is more likely
um surely it's not a um a good idea and
it might
essentially make you lose money now
there's some interesting variant of this
this is for which they said for some
variants 20 the 23rd
coin flip was delayed by uh sometime 24
um minutes and what uh they then find is
in fact
weaker evidence what's called the
gambler's fallacy
which seems to sort of say that like
once you let the coin rest for a while
um uh people seem to think that like
letting the coin rest for a while
which sort of makes it um um uh
more likely i guess that the street
continues were less likely that
essentially
um black noise the keys so there's
people seem to have sort of these these
fairly um and i think that's fair to say
rational beliefs about
or biased beliefs about what's going to
happen next
and that seems to like um uh be easily
swayed by even similar
relatively small things it's like the
coin um needs to sort of revert
but if you wait for 24 minutes um not
too much um anymore
there's quite a bit of work on the
gamblers fallacy overall in various
settings that's just one setting to
illustrate this
um there's quite a bit of other work in
that area and it's a fairly robust
um finding that people found in the
literature
now a second pattern that people find is
what's called the hot hand fallacy
that's the idea that in particular
basketball fans or other
sort of types of sports fans
fans players coaches believe that there
is
systematic day-to-day variation and
players shooting performance again
that's for basketball but it's also true
for other sports
um so the performance of a player um
the idea is that the performance of a
player may sometimes be predictably
better than expected on the basis of the
player's
overall record and so what people would
say is like well that player is on fire
today or as a street shooter and so on
and so the idea here is that um on fire
today means that um
he or she is more likely to hit or hit
his or her shots
um and then on other days so that's to
say the prediction here is that made
shots should cluster together
like on one day you happen to be really
good or maybe in the first half or
second
half and um um uh
conditional having made a few shots the
next shot should be
much more more likely than a sort of
young traditional probability
um there's lots of work on this issue um
starting by gilovich and bologna and
torsk in 1985
people have gone back and forth between
saying like the
in fact um uh uh
there is sort of such a thing as a hot
hand or not the initial claims were
essentially there's no such thing people
believe that there's a hot hand um going
on and like players are really sort of
running hot
but in fact um they're not uh some other
evidence later showed maybe there is
actually such a thing that it was
contradicted again so it's kind of
complicated but overall it seems to me
that people
tend to be like players fans and so on
tend to be
quite over optimistic about uh
the hot hand and streaks happening in
reality
now one question is that seems kind of
like odd in some ways and so
on the other end it seems like there
sort of seemed to be uh the pattern
fallacy
and the gamra's finalists seem to be
opposites of each other
that is to say the gamma's fallacy is
the belief that the next outcome is
likely to be different from the previous
ones
like i showed you like if i show you
like um if you're gambling
you get like four reds now you say it's
going to be black next so if you have
like three heads then you think
your coin is going to show some tails
that's essentially saying like
you saw a bunch of like outcomes of one
kind the next one will likely be
different
on the other hand the part-time policy
is sort of saying like well it's
believed that the next
outcome is likely to be similar to the
previous ones
now what's going on here you can think
of both of these as a consequence of
what's called the belief and the law of
small numbers
now what is that we should all know the
law of large numbers which is
uh enlarged samples of independent draws
from a distribution the proportion of
different outcomes
closely reflects the underlying
probability so essentially once you have
sufficiently many draws from some
distribution the distribution will drop
converge to like um uh what you're
drawing from
now what's the belief in the law of
small numbers
well it's the belief that in small
samples the proportion of different
outcomes should reflect their underlying
uh probabilities so usually in the law
of large numbers it's called the
law of large numbers because you need
the large number of draws that's why
it's called that way
but people seem to think that the law of
large numbers
also applies to um small samples
and so um and so how does it explain our
our puzzle well then there's a question
on like does the person know the
underlying
distribution so if you think you know
the underlying distribution for example
if you are
thinking no for sure that the coin is
fair or like the roulette table is is
not cheating on you
you might sort of say well um roughly i
should see as many
um reds as i should see blacks or i
should see as many uh
heads as i should see um uh uh tails
and so now if i've seen if i have a
sample of like four draws if i
already have like four heads then i
might sort of think in that small sample
i need to see essentially a roughly
equal
um uh a fraction of like heads and tails
and therefore if i've seen four reds the
next one is due to be black
and of course that's that's not not true
because essentially the
large number does not apply to small
samples because it's called a large
number and not the law of small numbers
but mistakenly people seem to think uh
the law of small number
applies in contrast
if the person does not know the
distribution
the belief in the law of small numbers
can lead to the
hotend fallacy that's to say if you're
trying to learn about the distribution
of of of shots or like um the underlying
probability
if you see some good events in a row if
you see like three heads or three tails
and so on if you
see like a player making three shots in
a row
you might sort of try to infer or
today's a good day or a bad day
and people tend to over infer they tend
to think like they can learn more from
these three shots than they actually do
really to be able to estimate whether a
player
is running hot on a given day
you need quite a few um draws but people
think like if a player makes three shots
that already means that like his
probability of making
um good shots and that they are way
higher than it actually is
so essentially people mistakenly seem to
over infer from small
from a small number of um observations
what the underlying probability
distribution is and in that sense the
uh the belief in the law of small
numbers can lead to
um the hot hand fallacy as well so these
are essentially our
um sort of two um very different
conclusions that seem to come from the
same
underlying issue then the last issue i'm
going to
pattern i'm going to show you by the way
there's more patterns such as those but
i'm sort of just showing you three of
them to sort of
give you a sense of what's going on
remember the example that i showed you
um uh in the first lecture which was a
question about like
base rates or base rate neglect which is
the question about like 100 people have
hiv we have a test that is
99 accurate if a person tests positive
what's the probability of having the
disease
and so i told you this before the true
answer is 50 but quite a few of you
um answered 90 99 and sort of the
the uh a plausible infinite explanation
is that people probably forgot to take
into account how few people in the
population
have the disease um to start with and so
this is what's called the base rate
neglect when people are given some
new information people tend to or um
in this case i guess the test of like 99
being 99
accurate people tend to focus on that
piece of information
they tend to um neglect the underlying
base rate which in this case is like
100 people um tend to have
the disease to start with and again
that's sort of
a natural consequence of focusing uh too
much on like one central aspect
of hand which is the 99 accuracy of the
test
um in a way that's you know again can be
useful
but it's sort of systematically getting
people to make wrong choices
there's quite a bit of evidence um uh
showing this in the literature
and sort of here's again what you should
be doing and sort of here's the
probability of this is
uh trust me that this really is 50
now um the last piece uh here is uh
in terms of like um biases so
systematically biases
what i showed you so far was well
people have a hard time um making right
choices even in simple informational
environments now two-dimensional
learning is even more complicated
and what i mean by two-dimensional isn't
saying well um
if you try to learn about news or like
the accuracy of news if you watch news
online
or anywhere else you don't need to only
like learn about like
somebody gives you some information and
you try to update based on that
information
but rather you also need to learn at the
same time about the accuracy of
the piece of information that's given to
you that is to say if you watch
something online and the article
not only just you need to sort of
understand kind of like what to learn
from that information that piece of
information
but you also need to sort of understand
the underlying um source of it there's
quite a bit of work recently on on fake
news and sort of the question i'm like
can
people can people in fact detect
fake news does it have to do with like
partisanship in particular so you might
think that republicans or democrats
want certain news to be true so you
might sort of think that like
republicans are more likely to want to
believe news
that are biased towards republicans
democrats are more likely to believe
news that are more likely to be
democrats and sort of therefore they
might be more likely to
um uh uh trust fake news or fall for
fake news
david radz in fact seems like it has
actually at least in their work
uh it seems to have um and by the way
he's at mit in the marketing department
or at sloane and marketing uh in the
marketing group
um uh he seems to find that it's less
about partisanship but rather about
people being
not paying attention and being somewhat
lazy and making their choices and then
like
once you draw their attention to like
here's an article that might be
fake people might seem to be actually
quite good at um
learning about the accuracy of it
um now let me sort of just summarize um
for a bit and then see whether there's
any questions so
what i've shown you is essentially using
bayes rule is difficult or give you some
sense of it
i showed you like three systematic
deviations from beijing updating which
is the
gambler's fallacy this is the fun time
fallacy and
base rate neglect these are all
well-known deviations from bayesian
learning
now one and two have argued can be
explained by the belief in the law of
small numbers
um and there are really important
real implications of those types of
outcomes for example
uh one very nice recent paper um maddie
talked about it a little bit in
recitation but only very briefly
is this paper by kelly um shu and
co-authors
about decision-making by judges umpires
and loan officers
where essentially if you're a judge or
loan officer you see a bunch of
applications over time
and um judges teams seem to essentially
um engage in what's the the gambler's
fallacy
um that's to say like if they see three
applicants in a row that happen to be
very good or very bad
that uh tends to affect the following
applicant
that is to say judges um when they um
uh when they decide about parole and so
on if they have given parole several
times in a row
they might think you know the next
person who's in line
if they've grounded parole several times
in a row the next person then would be
less likely to get paroled
even though of course these these are
independent events it just happens to be
that
one person happens to be after or before
certain applicants uh
random way so there's really sort of
important decisions that the gambler's
fallacy might
might affect uh and more recently when
you think about basically neglect in
some sense the example that i showed you
seems to be like a fairly academic
example in some ways
but when you think about like and i
don't want to talk too much about kobe
19
since you see that in your life too much
already anyway but if you think about
like um
tests for combat 19 there is now
talk about antibody tests and
particularly as tests that seem to be
highly informative in some sense there's
sensitivity and specificity
meaning like the type and two errors are
pretty low or their
sensitivity and specificity is is very
high these tense
tests tend to be highly accurate but in
fact
the how much you can learn from those
tests is actually very limited if the
overall fraction of people who are
infected is not that high
that's exactly the example that i just
showed you if the fraction of people
who are positive in the overall
population is relatively low
you are doing a test and essentially um
uh
receiving a negative a signal actually
is not
giving you um a lot of information
overall
this is precisely people tend to miss
that pack precisely because of
base rate neglect let me stop here for a
second that was a little bit fast so let
me see
if there's any comments or questions
right so then let me in the last um 10
minutes talk a little bit about
um heuristics and biases and this is
what kind of an adversity really
are um very well known um for so
the way to think about that biases and
probability judgments this is what we
already discussed the starting point is
that applying the laws of probability
and statistics is often impossibly hard
so people use their quick and intuitive
judgments to make likelihood estimates
and so there's a seminal work by um kind
of an adversity and lots of secret work
that sort of tries to like
think about these biases
if you're interested in learning more
about this is uh thinking um fast and
slow by
um um danny kahneman danny kahneman is
really sort of a
terrific book uh about thinking about
this now what's a heuristic
it's an informal algorithm that
generates an approximate answer to a
problem uh
quickly and therefore because it's sort
of like informal it's
it's kind of hard to to model well the
previous
um things that i showed you so i showed
you before
let me just go back for a second the
gambler's fallacy hotend fallacy
and base rate neglect here you can sort
of do
reasonably you can sort of like write
down models that
um uh uh capture these phenomena pretty
well
right you could for example for the base
rate neglect you could just have a
parameter
as like how much people how much weight
do people put in the base rate how much
people
uh how much weight do people put in like
the new information that they get
and then that parameter will essentially
sort of you can estimate that parameter
and you can write down a model that's
not bayesian but sort of close division
similarly for the hot hand fallacy and
gambler's house you can sort of
model that people essentially apply the
law of small numbers
and again that's a model you can write
down and estimate
in contrast some of the stuff that i'm
showing you next it's much more
difficult to model because in some sense
um some basic laws of probability
do just not apply anymore in a sense
that people don't respect them anymore
when they make their belief
updating let me show you um in a second
what i mean by that
but again heuristics have a good and the
bad side so they speed up and make
possible um conditions if they help you
make decisions in your everyday lives
and without heuristics
it would be really hard to make any
decisions uh overall
but because they're shortcuts they're
occasionally producing correct answers
or biases
so these are essentially unintended side
effects of sort of adaptive processes
and you know that makes it very useful
to study heuristics and biases together
you know in the same way as you would
study vision and optical illusion
together
studying them jointly um is very helpful
because they're sort of the product or
the result of the same thing
things are hard therefore they use
heuristics and because they use
heuristics
um that leads to systematic um biases
okay so now i'm going to show you like a
few of those risks just to give you a
sense of what these are
um one of the most well-known ones is
what's called the representativeness
heuristic
which is about linda linda is 21 years
old
single outspoken and very bright she
majored in philosophy as a student she
was deeply concerned with issues of
discrimination and social justice and
also participated in anti-nuclear
demonstrations
the question comes then rank the
following statements from
most to least probable and so
here's the statements you can read about
them all sorts of different things
in particular what kind of at first we
are following uh focusing on is
um items six and eight and
um uh item six is linda is a bank teller
and item eight is linda as a bank teller
and this is active in the feminist
movement now one thing that should be
clear is that like
six is more likely it's an eight because
essentially eight is sort of
conditioning on two statements
while six is only conditioning on one so
like
if linda is um number eight she of
course
it's implied that she if she's a bank
teller and something else
of course then she also is a bank teller
so it should always be the case that six
is more likely
than eight but what people tend to do um
uh quite consistently is that in fact
people
um rank it more likely that linda is
both a bank teller and a feminist then
then she's a bank teller and there's
quite a bit of
work on this and they showed this in
various ways
but essentially it's what's called the
violation of the conjunction rule which
is sort of a very basic law of
probability
and precisely because it's such a basic
law of probability it's hard to actually
model this because essentially you can't
use simple things that
you know should be true in probability
um theory
there's some potential concerns about
this people misunderstanding this
but there's sort of subsequent
experiments that essentially show that
um
that's not the case now what's going on
here is what's
kind of an university called the
representativeness heuristic which
people
essentially use similarity or
representativeness as a proxy of
for probabilistic thinking so based on
the um
available information people form a
mental image of what linda
might be like and then ask then um what
is she
um how likely is that uh
for example she's a schoolteacher they
might ask them how similar is is my
picture of linda to that of the school
teacher and so then turn this similar
similarity judgment and the probability
of judgment so here of course the
example was very much like rigged in the
sense of like they were doing the asking
things about like discrimination and
social justice and anti-nuclear
demonstration and so on
which made people think like well that's
a person that's likely to be part of the
feminist
movement and then people focus on that
by making these choices and they forget
the fact that like essentially
six must be by sort of definition more
likely
than eight so that's a common thing that
people use there's quite a bit of
evidence
of that um
and again that's a very reasonable
heuristic and it probably works in many
cases but it also leads to very
predictably bad
prediction choices and it's a poor
predictor of true
probability in in several situations
similarly sort of what's called the
availability heuristic people
um assess the probability of an event by
ease of which instances occurrences can
be
brought to mind so when you ask people
um for example about are they more
likely
are there more suicides or homicides in
the usage here
people will think about
suicides and homicides that they can
recall they might think about like what
they watched in tv and so on and they
judge the frequency of each based on how
many instances they can recall
and people will be much more likely to
recall homicides because they are much
more salient in the world
and that leads to people to think that
murders are way more common which in
fact
is is not the case again it's a very
sensible heuristic that people use
more often than not it's easier to
recall things that are uh more common or
are probable so you know that's
reasonable overall but again there's
sort of predictably
things that are then more salient but
get more attention
people tend to think they're much more
likely than they in fact
are let me skip the familiarity and
i'm anchoring adjustment and just sort
of like
conclude so what have you learned about
beliefs
overall so we studied several reasons
why people might miss information and
fail to learn
we talked about attention attention is
limited and therefore they might miss
things
he talked about like why might they miss
important things well because they might
have wrong theories
um of the world uh let me discuss people
might
derive utility from wrong beliefs and
therefore or might actually not want to
learn how much but
be systematically engaged and like
trying to deceive themselves
and then we talked about people it might
be a bad invasion
um learning now what's important here i
want you to take away it's important to
understand these underlying reasons why
people are misinformed
because they might lead to vastly
different policy implications
for example if you were to make
information salient make sense if
people think if you think people
misinformation and important
things in the world so if you for
example think that people just might
not be aware of the fact that certain
foods have more calories than others
then making like that information very
salient to people when they purchase
things
drawing their attention to that stuff
could be really important it could be
really powerful and helping people make
better
choices right or if they think just they
have like wrong theories of the world if
they think you know calories are not
that important
or if they miss the fact that smoking
causes cancer well you should really
sort of
draw their attention to them and help
them understand it and that's kind of
what a lot of labeling a lot of sort of
making things salient
uh often is about now
but if people don't want to learn if
people actually have motivated beliefs
in certain ways and in fact
they know that in some ways deep down in
them
inside they know that the relevant
information already
smokers for example might know exactly
that
smoking is bad for the health so
providing them with information about
smoking will not actually
um uh uh make them learn um
or like if you wanted to give somebody
information about like how to best take
care of your health when it comes to
huntington's well that's
not helpful if the person doesn't
actually want to believe that they have
hunting and
they sort of they're never even gonna
read what you send them if they want to
maintain their positive image about
their positive
uh uh their positive beliefs about their
health
and in fact um when people derive
utility from beliefs
correcting those beliefs can make them
worse off
right if somebody wants to believe that
for the next they know kind of like the
probability of having hunting is
reasonably high
but they want to maintain the beliefs
that they're healthy and they want to be
happy for the next 10 or 20 years
and then maybe at some point the disease
will break out but their choice is they
want to be
think that they're healthy and they want
don't do not want to adjust their
behavior
so who are we then to tell them um
otherwise that's their choice if it
makes them like less happy
uh we might actually make them worse off
so in some ways there's at least some
arguments for respecting people's
choices
if they want to be diluted if they want
to delude themselves
and the consequences are not severe in
the sense of peace are situations where
they can't really
do much about then in fact leaving
people uninformed might be the right
thing
to do and then sort of understanding
systematic
biases based on heuristics kind of help
improve decisions
um that's in some sense a lot less
controversial if you think that people
are systematically making wrong choices
because they learn sort of wrongly and
they just have like wrong information in
their heads
sort of providing them with the correct
information seems like an ambiguously
uh something one should do um that's all
i have
on uh uh on beliefs for you next time
we're gonna talk about projection and
attribution bias
but i'm also happy to answer any
questions in the next few minutes
if you have on this lecture or on the
summary that i just